If your handwriting is bad then you
can never get good marks in CBSE.
Here, yes, only those who have good handwriting
get good marks. You know
why it is a
simple question, children, CBSE people
have a lot of papers to check.
So if you do not write,
then it is possible that the
examiner who checks what you have written may not
understand it. So what is my tip, please write
needsli. If you feel that your
cursive writing is not good then
Write the words spaced apart, write single letters,
so that what you have written is easy to
understand and if it is an easy exam, you can understand it and you
get the marks you get appropriately. I thought all I hope it
by
[Music]